welcome oops no welcome to this video
playing international master fighting
dragon from the from the net from
Germany let's see us he got the name
cast John kupka I had done I know the
name but I don't know him personally
okay I'm like a golf variation with a
night a six and c6 ok trying to play
quickly here even at the risk of not
hitting the most precise moves 92 is
played in 10 in anticipation of e 5 i
have also sharples here but i don't i
don't want to play it so sharply just
down set up a solid position first hear
that seem yeah okay he's switching back
to her to benoni this i think this is
surprising really to be no knee back him
I put my pieces are not so so I'm badly
positioned for a benoni I came anyway
the question is I am after ed I can also
take with the upon playing I'm playing
it in a more restrained fashion ok don't
to mind this this type of position yeah
well this is this is some part of my
position agenda anyway g-form I don't
mind that that you provoked me to do it
want to want to win space here on the
Kings side okay what is he doing f5
maybe maybe hmm yeah this is not so well
coordinated at the moment I must admit
but so maybe i mistimed this with chief
or not sure ok let's some too late to
fix now want to get the night to g3 ok
so is hmm threatening f/4g five maybe my
hat's that's really not a good position
he can go g5 I don't really know what to
do against that ok maybe it's
frightening f4 after 35 yeah ok this is
also possible more
but the solution based more on piece
play yeah it's not very nice
I do I don't see anything brilliant for
him but the position looks really really
shaky it feels like there should be some
tactic but yeah okay here i can play a
form everything else fails okay let's do
that
hmm yeah surprisingly if this is not so
bad unless I'm overlooking something
that's that's of course possible he's
taking some time probably because he
thinks there is something and he doesn't
find it by now I think I'm coordinated
well enough okay the question is what
now interesting position I can also
consider to take the ship takes Knight
takes Queen takes Bishop g4 is not not
so bad there's also g5 which I can play
yeah okay I'm not sure both look they've
they both look interesting yeah okay
must take now pawn takes then be sure
that form idea then H form establishing
the space advantage you still has those
pieces on a six and term and nt7 that
don't do so much
threatening to take now in d6 yeah just
try to double on the phone now night
Knight to f4
okay b5 Hammond the only kind of counter
play should I go age five now or stem
but something better before yeah yeah
before preemptive strike him before he
goes b5 himself and what now being aged
five not sure okay let's let some fix
the space edge space advantage him he
cannot do much really and I always have
aged five coming okay
hmm not sure nitey six also might be a
move okay this is probably better still
check night g6 check
that's not really leading time and we
attack no I don't believe that he
managed in five seconds to take up on my
pawn this is stupid oh this is one of
the worst losses for ages like a lie I
give me that Japanese suicide sword I
mean really not paying attention anymore
I really thought I really thought my
pawns go through him yeah of course it's
winning in every way possible just just
advance with the king it's really
doesn't matter I thought they just go
through and now they don't they simply
don't yeah this is some this position is
surprisingly resilient probably I played
some some something some bed set up here
yet so it's not clear at all him not
cleared on check when this is now just
winning because of five faults but he
simply shouldn't take him up on e2 can
can play various moves this one for
example
hmm ciao yeah that's surprisingly tough
this position I mean it's very one-sided
but it's not like I have a an easy win
available at least I don't find some I
don't find anything the computer is also
only giving a slight advantage yeah yeah
to lose this can of one-sided game is
always frustrating Jack where you could
generally ever do anything yeah simply I
simply thought the pawns promote and of
course I largely need to rely on pre
moves here but they don't simply don't
promote this isn't hacked still a draw
but okay I have nine seconds and there
was a bit too to stunt anyway yeah okay
thanks for watching